[Música]
ya en el estudio para hablar de revista
de prensa bienvenida a este lunes
después de las vacaciones de semana
santa Buenos días Rodrigo buenos días
Rosa y vamos a comenzar hablando del
periódico el país que hoy titula la
filtración de documentos secretos del
pentágono en internet vuelve a enfrentar
a Estados Unidos e Israel Este es un
artículo de la periodista María Antonia
Sánchez Vallejo Rosa cuéntanos qué ha
escrito esta periodista en el país en
Rodrigo pues como decías no para
presentar esta sección esta filtración
de documentos que todo apunta son de la
inteligencia estadounidense y una
titulares a lo largo y ancho del planeta
y uno de los temas reflejados en estos
documentos es precisamente una nueva
digamos etapa de tensión entre Estados
Unidos e Israel y eso porque bien porque
en unos en uno de los de los documentos
se señala que la inteligencia
estadounidense culpa a la inteligencia
israelí es decir le hacía culpa a la
mosach Por decirlo rápidamente de estar
de de las protestas masivas que han
tenido lugar en Israel desde principios
de este año 2023 en contra del gobierno
de Benjamín netanyahu y particularmente
en contra de la Reforma al sistema
judicial no bien a esta ha sido una
información que tanto la propia mossad
como la oficina del Primer Ministro han
desmentido y esto por qué añade más leña
al fuego bien porque hace unas semanas
la Casa Blanca llegó a decir
públicamente algo poco habitual que Joe
biden había llamado personalmente a
Benjamín netanyahu para decirle en
resumidas cuentas que retirara no esta
reforma judicial que Israel se estaba
jugando su imagen como única democracia
de medio oriente desde luego no le
interesa nada Estados Unidos que la
imagen y el no sé cómo que el ámbito
social en Israel esté un poco
deteriorado y hablan de ello también New
York Times una rosa Sí exactamente Y es
que el New York Times hace un repaso una
rápida Rodrigo a lo que ha sido esta
filtración digamos de inteligencia
estadounidense que algunos medios han
calificado como la más peligrosa en
décadas de hecho bien Es que el New York
Times fue uno de los primeros medios de
comunicación que hizo referencia esta
filtración que empezó en Portales de
internet como discord pero rápidamente
pasó a Telegram o a Twitter no bien el
New York Times plantea una serie de
preguntas que quedan abiertas e intenta
resolverlas con Fuentes expertas en el
ámbito por un lado recordemos que esta
filtración como bien decía Rodrigo hace
referencia sobre todo a información
relativa a la situación de la guerra en
Ucrania por lo tanto pregunta New York
Times son reales los documentos dice
según analistas militares en gran parte
Sí precisamente esto ha preocupado no a
funcionarios tanto estadounidenses como
ucranianos como rusos por la exposición
pública no de esta información tan
secreta bien dice De dónde provendrían
estos documentos filtración son un
hackeo todo apunta a una filtración Por
qué dice el New York Times parecen
fotografías tomadas apresuradamente de
papeles colocados encima de lo que
parece ser una revista de caza parece
que se ha cogido no este papel se ha
doblado en un bolsillo y que luego se
sacó en un área segura para ser
fotografiados bien Dice que nos enseñan
particularmente de la guerra en Ucrania
no Grana cosa que no supiéramos de Cómo
se desarrolla la situación sobre el
terreno pero sí que dan informaciones
sobre la posición de tropas y sobre cómo
la otan pretende armarlas de Cara a esta
esperada contraofensiva ucraniana de
primavera dice ha penetrado Estados
Unidos en la inteligencia rusa parece
que sí y que mucho de hecho dice la New
York Times toda esta inteligencia
refuerza la idea de que Estados Unidos
tiene más acceso a digamos a los planes
rusos de atacar Ucrania que no a la
forma de Ucrania defenderse no y bien
estas son algunas de las informaciones
destacables entre muchas otras que hacen
referencia a otros países como a Israel
como comentábamos a principio de esta
Crónica y a mí la pregunta que me surge
y quizás también a nuestros televidentes
es quien ha filtrado esto y por qué la
verdad claro Rodrigo es que de hecho
tanto que es como Moscú se acusan
mutuamente de estar utilizando esta
filtración como arma de guerra híbrida
no digamos que se acusan también un poco
por la cuenta que les trae de digamos
estar intentando despistarse no
despistar al enemigo con informaciones
que según ellos dicen serían falsas bien
todo este tema seguramente o quizás no
no se irá desarrollando a lo largo de
los próximos días Pero algunas de las
informaciones que han preocupado también
Rodrigo ha aliados de Estados Unidos han
sido las que hacen referencia por
ejemplo a Corea del Sur no y es que ha
salido revelado en estos documentos que
Washington está intentando presionar del
sur por ejemplo para que envíe armamento
a Ucrania no está entre bueno muchos de
los datos que dan estos documentos salgo
de lo que habla también en New York
Times en estos en estas filtraciones
tanto papel aquí Rosa que parece esto la
oficina de The Office vamos con temas
más serios porque hayas ira también
tiene hoy cosas interesantes de las que
vamos a hablar y dice que es probable
que Ucrania se enfrente a una Sangrienta
lucha en crimea según muestran imágenes
satelitales Rosa De qué hemos visto en
esas imágenes satelitales de Jessica
bien pues estas imágenes que analiza el
jazzira Como hizo el Washington post
Hace unos días muestran lo que parecen
trincheras que estarían siendo cavadas
por las fuerzas rusas en la Península de
crimea para defenderse en torre de lo
que Rusia Ya ve no como una inminente
digamos ofensiva ucraniana para
recuperar este territorio que recordemos
hasta Bueno desde 2014 está bajo control
a ruso de facto no y de hecho Rusia ha
colocado en ese vastopol en esta en esta
Península de crimea su principal base
naval de hecho por esto mismo señalada
este artículo de jazzira que es tan
fácil no de defender para Rusia esta
península que además geográficamente
representa uno de los puntos más
defendibles del planeta bien en
resumidas cuentas lo que dice al jazzira
es que sería muy difícil para Ucrania
llegar a retomar esta península que
además los aliados de Ucrania no lo ven
como una de los de las prioridades sino
que lo ven como algo muy difícil no y
muy peligroso porque y ha dicho Vladimir
Putin que al considerar crimea
territorio ruso digamos que un ataque
contra crimea desataría no una respuesta
gran escala que incluso podría implicar
el uso de armas nucleares tácticas bien
Rodrigo veremos lo que pasa pero
concluye este artículo de jazzira que si
bien Esto digamos
haría más peligroso el conflicto no
dificultaría más el conflicto también
poner en riesgo el control
ruso de la Península crimea sería una de
las formas quizás de acabarlo claro es
la clave quizás de la posible paz en
Ucrania y tú estuviste hace poco
entrevistando a josep borrel el jefe de
la diplomacia europea no se quiso mojar
sobre este tema Rosa exactamente Rodrigo
Bueno nos vemos mañana para continuar
hablando de la prenda internacional